Étienne Clin, bonjour.
Bonjour. Nous vous recevons pour une
chaîne YouTube qui s'appelle Syerview,
une chaîne internet qui diffuse en
direct sur de multiples plateformes.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
émission spéciale sur le boson de Higs.
On vous a demandé de revenir après notre
première interview que nous avons fait
il y a quelques semaines et vous êtes
revenu, vous avez tenu parole et on va
vous écouter aujourd'hui sur le boson de
X. Est-ce que vous pouvez être comme
vous êtes d'habitude ? Simple, clair,
net et précis.
Je vais essayer. Je m'étais engagé à
revenir pour parler de cette belle
histoire de la physique sans mesurer à
quoi m'engage cet engagement parce que
c'est une histoire compliquée. Alors
pour la rendre accessible, il faut que
j'explique deux ou trois choses du
contexte. La première chose c'est que on
est en mai 2018. On célèbre les 50 ans
de mai 68. Un des slogans qui était les
plus
les plus prononcés à l'époque, c'était
"Soyons réalistes, demandons
l'impossible".
Et mon idée c'est que la physique, c'est
la la contrapposée de ce slogan. C'est
presque l'inverse. C'est "Soyons
impossible, demandons le réel." Alors,
il y a deux façons de comprendre cette
proposition étrange. La première, c'est
de dire finalement, "En effet, les
physiciens, ils cherchent à comprendre
ce qu'on appelle le réel. De quoi est-il
constitué ? Quelles sont les lois qui
régissent la matière, les particules qui
la constituent ? Qu'est-ce qu'un atome ?
Comment est-ce qu'il émet de la lumière
? Comment est-ce qu'il absorbe de la
lumière ? Donc, il s'agit de comprendre
comment fonctionne le réel empirique. Et
puis une autre façon de comprendre cette
proposition, soyons impossible de mon
nom de réel, elle vient d'un d'un
philosophe des sciences du 20e siècle
qui s'appelle Alexandre Ciré qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur Galilée, sur la
naissance de la physique moderne et lui
faisait remarquer que le pari de la
physique,
c'est qu'on peut expliquer le réel par
l'impossible. Ce qu'il voulait dire par
là, c'est que les lois physiques, celles
qu'on apprend à l'école et même celle
qu'on apprend beaucoup plus tard qu'à
l'école sont des lois qui au premier
abord
contredisent l'observation, c'est-à-dire
elles disent des choses dont on ne voit
pas immédiatement la contrepartie dans
le spectacle des phénomènes physiques
auquels nous assistons. Je prends un
exemple. Galilée, un des inventeurs de
la physique moderne énonce en 1604 l'une
des premières grandes lois de la
physique à savoir que tous les corps
tombent à la même vitesse dans le vide.
À une époque où on ne sait pas faire le
vide, on discute même de son existence.
Donc ce qu'il dit là est un énoncé que
personne ne peut vérifier puisque quand
on fait tomber des cords de masses
différentes d'une grande hauteur dans
l'atmosphère, on voit qu'en gros les
plus lourds tent plus vite que les plus
légers. On voit même que c'est compliqué
parce que si on met un parachute à un
corps lourd, il il peut tomber moins
vite qu'un corps plus léger. Donc c'est
très compliqué la phénoménologie de la
chute des corps. Et Galilée arrive, il
dit tous les corps, quel que soit leur
masse tombent à la même vitesse dans le
vide. Pensez à un autre principe
fondamental de la mécanique, ce qu'on
appelle le principe d'inertie. Un corps
qui n'est soumis à aucune force à un
mouvement rectile et uniforme. C'est il
continue en ligne droite indéfiniment.
Mais qui a jamais vu un tel mouvement ?
personne. Et donc on a des lois
physiques qui correspondent à des
situations qui ne sont pas directement
observables ou qui en tout cas oblige à
réinterroger l'observation pour
expliquer comment des lois qui
contredisent les phénomènes expliquent
les phénomènes.
Et donc la physique c'est pas la
bureaucratie des apparences. Ça ne
consiste pas à regarder ce qui est, à
voir les phénomènes tels que il se
manifestent à nous et à extraire de
cette observation des lois physiques. En
fait, il faut trouver des stratagèmes
intellectuels pour que le réel décoïcide
de ce qu'il nous montre. Galilée, il a
trouvé cette loi non pas en faisant
d'expérience, mais en interrogeant des
lois supposées vraies de l'époque en
montrant que si on les supposait vrai,
alors on pouvait imaginer des situations
qui conduisent à des conclusions
absurdes. Einstein fera la même chose un
peu plus tard. Donc ça c'est le premier
point. Faire de la physique finalement
comme le disait Bachelard, c'est penser
contre son cerveau, c'est-à-dire c'est
accepter des messages, des lois par
exemple que notre cerveau a du mal à
accepter parce que ces lois contredisent
nos préjugés, ce que nous croyons
évident et les phénomènes tels qu'ils se
montrent à nous. Voilà. Ensuite, l'autre
point qui servira dans la suite de mon
propos, c'est d'essayer de réfléchir à
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire quand
apparaît soudain une contradiction
entre une mesure qu'on peut faire ou une
observation qu'on peut faire et une loi
physique venant d'une théorie en
laquelle on a acquis une certaine
confiance. On a une théorie physique, on
a confiance dans cette théorie, puis
tout d'un coup, une mesure, une
observation montre que il y a un
désaccord entre ce qu'on perçoit, ce
qu'on mesure et puis ce que dit la
théorie. Qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire ?
Alors, je vais vous donner quelques
exemples et l'histoire du Bosix va
s'inscrire dans cette longue histoire.
Au début du 19e siècle, on regarde enfin
les astronomes regardent avec attention
la trajectoire de la planète Uranus qui
tourne autour du soleil selon une
trajectoire elliptique qu'on peut
calculer grâce à la théorie Newton de la
gravitation.
On voit, on observe cette trajectoire et
elle est à peu près conforme à ce qu'on
peut calculer grâce aux équations
Newton. Mais on finit par observer un
petit désaccord entre la trajectoire
qu'on observe et ce que donne le calcul.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? La plupart des
astronomes, même la maj la très grande
majorité
considère à l'époque que la théon a fait
ses preuves
et donc il faut lui faire confiance.
Et le petit désaccord qu'on observe doit
être dû à la présence d'une planète
qu'on a jamais vu
qui par son effet gravitationnel sur
Uranus
explique le petit désaccord entre ce que
prévoit le calcul et ce que donne la
mesure.
On fait des calculs en France, en
Angleterre et on envoie ces calculs à un
astronome allemand qui s'appelle Gal qui
le soir même du jour où il reçoit les
calculs pointe son télescope à l'endroit
calculé. voit une tâche lumineuse,
attend la nuit pour vérifier que c'est
bien une planète et non pas une étoile
fixe et le lendemain annonce la
découverte d'une nouvelle planète qui
s'appelle Neptune. Donc Neptune a été
calculé mathématiquement avant d'être
détecté pour combler un ou disons
réconcilier la terre de Newton avec
l'observation. Ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
une solution ontologique. Quand il y a
un désaccord, on va le réduire en
supposant qu'il existe quelque chose
qu'on ne connaît pas encore qui s'il
existe rétablit les l'accord entre la
mesure et la théorie. Je vous donne un
autre exemple. Dans les années 20
du 20e siècle, cette fois,
euh, on étudie un phénomène qui
s'appelle la radioactivité beta. La
radioactivité beta, en gros, c'est un
noyau, un noyau d'atome que j'appelle A
qui se transforme en un noyau B
en émettant un électron. Il y a un
électron qui sort. Par exemple, ça peut
être du potassium 40. Le symbole
chimique, c'est K. potassium 40, c'est
l'isotope devient du calcium 40
avec émission d'un électron.
Alors, on va finir par comprendre qu'en
fait, c'est un neutron du noyau qui est
là qui devient un proton
plus un électron. Donc, c'est une
désintégration en deux corps du neutron
qui devient spontanément
un proton et un électron. on voit un
électron qui sort du noyau euh ce qui
est assez surprenant parce qu'à l'époque
on ne savait pas trop ce qu'il y avait
dans le noyau.
Et quand on fait un calcul qui s'appuie
sur la conservation de l'énergie et ben
il apparaît que l'électron là il doit
toujours avoir la même énergie. Quel que
soit le corps qu'il émet, ça doit
toujours être la même énergie pour
l'électron. Et à cette époque, fin des
années 20, on commence à pouvoir mesurer
l'énergie de l'électron. On s'attend à
trouver un spectre comme on dit donc en
fonction de l'énergie d'électron.
le nombre d'électrons qui ont une
énergie grande, on s'attend à ce qu'en
gros ça soit une valeur bien déterminée
avec une petite barre d'erreur
et quand on fait les mesures, on trouve
quelque chose de complètement différent.
On trouve tout un spectre
que l'électron
expérimentalement
peut avoir n'importe quelle valeur de
l'énergie entre zéro et la valeur qu'on
avait calculé. Et donc il y a un
désaccord entre ce que prévoyait le
calcul et ce que montre la mesure.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Alors il y a beaucoup de physiciens qui
disent "Mais ça prouve que les calculs
s'appuyent sur des hypothèses fausses et
qu'en l'occurrence on n pas le droit de
dire que l'énergie est conservée parce
que c'est en disant que l'énergie est
conservée
qu'on prévoit une valeur fixe pour
l'électron pour l'énergie de l'électron.
En fait, il y a un jeune physicien qui
s'appelle Volgong Paoli, autrichien, qui
vit à Zuric à l'époque, il a 28 ou 29
ans. Il a vit une sorte de crise
existentielle parce que sa femme l'a
quitté pour un chimiste, ce qui est
toujours très dur pour un physicien
théoricien. Et lui, il va faire
l'hypothèse dans une sorte de de rêve
bizarre qu'en fait la désintégration du
neutron
ne se fait pas en deux corps
mais en trois corps. Il y a une
troisième particule qui est émise qui
emporte l'énergie manquante de sorte que
si on suppose qu'elle existe, on
rétablit l'accord entre la prédiction du
calcul et l'observation. On va pas le
prendre au sérieux. Enfin, celui qui va
le prendre au sérieux pour la première
fois, c'est un physicien italien qui
s'appelle Enrico Fermi et qui va
baptiser cette particule dont
l'existence est supposé par Paul d'un
nom italien neutrino. Neutrino veut dire
petit du neutron en italien. D'accord ?
Ça c'est 1932.
Et en fait, le neutrino sera découvert
expérimentalement en 1955
grâce à la mise en service du premier
réacteur nucléaire américain. Les
réacteurs nucléaires sont des
dispositifs qui émettent beaucoup de
neutrinaux parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
désintégrations de ce genre dans le cœur
du réacteur. Et donc là encore, on a une
solution ontologique
au conflit entre la théorie et
l'observation. On rétablit l'accord en
disant il y a dans le réel quelque chose
qu'on ne connaissait pas qui s'il
existe. Rétablit l'accord en
l'occurrence ça été le neutrino. Mais en
fait il y a des cas où ça marche pas
comme ça. Par exemple fin 19e siècle on
regarde une autre planète que Uranus. On
regarde la planète qui est la plus
proche du soleil qui est la planète
Mercure. Elle a une trajectoire
elliptique
et on regarde comment cette trajectoire
évolue rotation après rotation.
Et on voit que le pil le péri le
périlisme donc si je mets ici le soleil
donc il y a Mercure qui tourne comme ça
le périlisme c'est le point le plus
proche du soleil sur la trajectoire de
Mercure qui est une trajectoire
angroelliptique mais on voit que tour
après tour bah le péril il se se décale
légèrement
il tourne il tourne légèrement on peut
le calculer par Newton mais on trouve
que les mesures donnent un désaccord
faible
qu'on peut pas considérer comme nul.
C'est que les calculs de Newton, un peu
comme c'était le cas pour Uranus, ne
disent pas exactement ce qui se passe
pour la trajectoire de la planète
Mercure. L'écart est tout petit, c'est
43 secondes d'arc par siècle.
43 secondes d'arc, c'est un angle qui
correspond à peu près à l'épaisseur d'un
cheveux que je vois depuis une distance
d'un m. Donc c'est vraiment un angle
ridicule. Alors, on pourrait dire c'est
zéro. C'est comme si c'était zéro. Mais
non, c'est pas zéro, c'est 43 secondes
d'art par siècle. Alors, les gens se
disent "Ben, on va refaire le même type
de calcul que pour Uranus."
Ils sont d'ailleurs tellement sûr d'eux
puisque la détection de Neptune a
confirmé que leur façon de procéder
était la bonne. Elle a augmenté leur
confiance dans les équations Newton. Et
donc ces gens calculent la trajectoire
que doit avoir une planète pour pour
expliquer ce petit désaccord par son
action gravitationnelle sur Mercure. Il
la baptise Vulkin cette planète avant
même de la détecter. Ils la baptisent.
Ce qui veut dire qu'ils sont vraiment
sûr d'eux. Il la bâtise Vulcin. Les
astronomes la cherchent dans le ciel la
trouvent pas. Alors ils font toutes
sortes d'hypothèses. C'est une planète
diluée, c'est un gaz, elle est diffuse,
elle est pas concentrée, et cetera.
Et puis il y a un jeune homme qui arrive
et qui dit "Ce petit désaccord là, c'est
la preuve que les équations Newton sont
fausses. La théorie de la gravitation
Newton est fausse." Et ce jeune homme,
il s'appelle Einstein et il va formuler
une nouvelle théorie de la gravitation
qui va publier en 1915 qui s'appelle la
théorie de la relativité générale. Et
l'un des premiers calculs qu'il va
faire, c'est de calculer le la variation
de la position de péridie rotation après
rotation. il va trouver exactement la
valeur qui avait été obtenue par les
astronomes. Et donc voyez, quand il y a
un désaccord entre la théorie et une
mesure, il y a des cas dans l'histoire
de la physique où c'est une solution
ontologique
qui a donné la bonne solution. On
postule qu'il existe des choses qui
rétablissent l'accord. Et puis il y a
des cas comme celui que je viens de
citer avec Mercure où la solution est
législative.
Il faut changer la loi pour interpréter
l'écart qu'il y a entre une observation
et la loi d'avant qui était fausse.
Voilà. Et ce qui est intéressant dans le
cas du boson de X, c'est que comme vous
allez voir, on va mélanger à l'issue de
la détection d'un désaccord
ontologique et une solution législative.
Alors là, ça m'amène à parler un petit
peu du monde des particules, du monde
des interactions fondamentales.
Alors, quand on est au lycée, on apprend
que une interaction, elle est médiatisée
par un champ dans l'espace. Par exemple,
si je prends une particule chargée, un
électron
euh par exemple qui a une charge
négative, il va créer autour de lui dans
l'espace un champ électromagnétique. Et
si je mets dans ce champ une autre
particule chargée, elle va subir une
force qui est liée à l'intensité de ce
champ à l'endroit où il se trouve. Donc
les interactions sont transmises par
l'entremise d'un champ dans l'espace.
Or, dans les années 20 du 20e siècle, il
y a une révolution en physique, en plus
de la relativité générale dont je viens
de parler, qui s'appelle la physique
quantique. Et la physique quantique,
elle a obligé à repenser ce qu'on
appelle une interaction. C'est qu'une
interaction entre deux objets est aussi
une affaire d'objets. C'est-à-dire qu'en
fait, quand deux particules
interagissent,
il faut imaginer qu'elles échangent
d'autres particules qui sont
caractéristiques de l'interaction
qu'elles subissent. Je vais vous donner
une analogie qui est une analogie fausse
comme toutes les analogies. Il faudrait
donc la critiquer mais elle permet de
comprendre de quoi je parle. Imaginez
que vous soyez sur un étant dans un
petit sur une embarcation là je la
représente vue de dessus.
Donc la l'embarcation
avance sur une certaine trajectoire.
Vous êtes dedans.
Voilà. Et puis il y en a une autre qui
est là comme ça
avec un autre passager
et les deux embarcations vont l'une vers
l'autre et on voit bien que si on ne
fait rien, c'est la collision. Vous
imaginez que les passagers ici n'ont pas
de paguet, pas de perche, pas de rame.
Ils n'ont donc pas moyen de d'orienter
ou de modifier la trajectoire de
l'embarcation.
Alors, ben imaginez que l'un des deux
possède un ballon, un ballon qui a une
certaine masse. Bon ben imaginez que ils
vont se faire des passes avec le ballon.
Lui, il va lancer le ballon. Celui-ci va
lancer le ballon à celui-là qui va la
renvoyer. Il va le renvoyer et cetera.
Ils vont se faire une succession de
passe et grâce à ces passes qu'il se
font, ça va créer une force répulsive
qui fait que les deux embarrications
vont finir par s'éloigner l'une de
l'autre. D'accord ? Bah cette cette
analogie
explique à peu près même s'il faut la
critiquer comme je l'ai dit comment ça
se passe les interactions entre
particules. En fait elles échangent des
ballons
qui sont caractéristiques de
l'interaction qu'elles subissent. Alors
maintenant quelles sont les interactions
qui existent dans le monde des
particules ? Il y a la gravitation
que je vais complètement laisser de côté
parce que c'est une force dont
l'intensité est tellement faible au
niveau des particules qu'on peut la
négliger. Alors, il reste trois forces
fondamentales, trois interactions
fondamentales comme on dit. La première,
c'est l'interaction électromagnétique.
On la connaît bien parce qu'elle fait
marcher nos appareils électroménagers,
hein.
Machine à laver. four à micro-ondes en
passant par le fer à repasser justement
et elle est aussi responsable du
fonctionnement du soleil. Non, pardon,
j'ai n'importe quoi, excusez-moi, c'est
pour plus tard. Non, des réactions
chimiques, de la cohésion de la matière
à notre échelle et cetera, de l'optique
et toutes ces phénomènes qu'on connaît
bien. D'accord ? Et bien
l'électromagnétique,
la l'interaction électromagnétique dans
le cadre de la physique quantique
est médiatisée par un ballon qui est le
quantum de lumière, ce qu'on appelle le
photon. Et donc faut il faut imaginer
que quand deux électrons se repoussent
par la force électrique, en fait ils
échangent des photons en permanence. Ces
photons, on les appellent des photons
virtuels. Virtuels parce que en fait ils
sont en dehors de leur couche de masse.
Enfin, on va pas aller dans les détails.
Disons que le ballon caractéristique
de l'interaction électromagnétique,
c'est le photon.
Ensuite, il y a une deuxième interaction
qui est l'interaction faible.
nucléaire faible par exemple, c'est
celle qui est responsable de la
désintégration d'un neutron en protoné
électron. D'accord ? Elle est donc
responsable de la radioactivité beta. Et
puis comme son nom l'indique, elle est
faible, ça veut donc elle est difficile
à détecter dans l'environnement. Par
contre, elle est responsable du
fonctionnement du soleil. C'est elle qui
est responsable du fait que le soleil
peut brûler son hydrogène à un rythme
très lent qui fait que la durée de vie
de notre étoile est de plusieurs
milliards d'années. D'accord ? Ben
l'interaction faible, elle est
médiatisée
par trois sortes de ballons. Il y en a
trois. Un appelle le W+.
Wick, ça veut dire faible en anglais.
Donc c'est le c'est le la particule
associée à l'interaction faible.
positive, il y a le W- avec une charge
négative et puis il y en a une trisè de
charge nulle qu'on appelle le Z0.
Ce sont les trois médiateurs de
l'interaction faible qui ont été prédits
par les théoriciens euh dans les années
60, qui ont été détectés
grâce à des collisions de particules au
CERN dans les années 80. Et ce sont des
particules de masse élevée. Leur masse,
c'est à peu près 90 fois la masse d'un
proton.
Donc c'est des particules très lourdes.
Le photon, j'aurais dû le dire, lui
comme vous le savez, il est une masse
nulle.
D'ailleurs, il y a il y a un rapport
entre la portée d'une interraction,
c'est la distance dans l'espace jusqu'à
laquelle elle peut agir et la masse des
ballons. Si la masse des ballons est
nulle, la portée d'interaction est
infinie. Si au contraire la masse des
ballons est très élevée, et bien le
transfert ne pourra se faire que si la
distance entre les deux embarcations est
petite. Et donc il y a un rapport entre
la masse des ballons et la portée
d'interaction. Pour que l'interaction a
une portée infinie comme l'interaction
électromagnétique, il faut que les
ballons aient une masse nulle, ce qui
est bien le cas pour les photons.
Ces particules là étant très massives,
la portée de l'interaction faible est
très petite. [raclement de gorge] C'est
presque une interaction de contact. pour
que deux particules interagissent. Il
faut qu'elles soient collées l'une à
l'autre. La portée, c'est de l'ordre de
1 millionniè de milliardièmes de mètres.
Donc c'est vraiment une portée toute
petite. Et puis il y a une troisième
interaction
qu'on appelle l'interaction forte.
Interaction nucléaire forte. D'accord ?
Alors, dans un noyau d'atomes, comme
vous le savez, il y a des protons et des
neutrons. Et en fait, on a découvert que
dans les protons et les neutrons, il y a
des particules plus petite qu'on appelle
les quarcs. Les quarc,
ce sont des particules qui constituent
les nucléons, les particules qui sont
dans les noyaux. Et bien, l'interaction
forte, c'est une interaction entre quarc
qui est médiatisée par des particules
qu'on appelle des gluons.
Voilà. Donc voilà pour les forces. Au
niveau des particules, il y en a trois
qu'il faut prendre en compte.
électromagnétique,
faible, forte, la gravitation, la de
côté. Maintenant, pour ce qui est des
particules élémentaires, en fait euh on
fait des distinctions assez simples. Il
y a des particules qui ne subissent pas
l'interaction forte,
elles sont pas sensibles. Et ces
particules, on les appelle des leptons.
Alors, en fait, il y en a il y en a six
de six sortes. Il y a par exemple
l'électron,
il y a une autre particule qui s'appelle
le muon qui une sorte d'électron lourd.
Il y en a un troisème qui s'appelle le
taux. Ces trois particules ont des
charges électriques et ont une masse non
nulle. Et puis leur sont associés trois
neutrinaux. Un neutrino pour l'électron,
un neutrino pour le myon, un neutrino
pour le taux. D'accord ? Donc ça fait
six leptons, six particules qui ne sont
pas sensibles à l'interaction nucléaire
forte. Et puis les particules qui sont
sensibles à l'interaction nucléaire
forte, on les appelle des adrons.
Et en fait, on on peut on a constaté que
il y en a des centaines, il y en a des
centaines de
de sortes différentes et elles sont de
deux types. Soit elles sont constituées
de trois quarcs,
soit elles sont constituées d'un quark
et d'un antiquarque. Antiquark, ça veut
dire antiparticule du quark. Je mets une
barre dessus pour le désigner. Ça, j'ai
pas entré dans le vocabulaire trop
détaillé, mais ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
des barons
et ça c'est ce qu'on appelle des
maisons.
D'accord ? Et donc faut imaginer qu'en
fait
l'interaction forte est une interaction
par laquelle les quarc interagissent en
échangeant des gluons.
Bon, la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on décrit tout ça ?
Comment est-ce qu'on décrit les
interactions entre particules ? Alors,
après la deuxème guerre mondiale, il y a
des physiciens thoriciens qui ont eu des
idées assez incroyable. [grognement] Ils
ont eu l'idée d'associer
euh chacune des interactions
à ce qu'on appelle un groupe de
symétrie. Alors, qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'une symétrie ? Dans la vie courante,
une symétrie, c'est une opération qui ne
change pas la forme d'un objet, qui le
laisse invariant. Par exemple, si je
prends une sphère
et si je fais tourner cette sphère
autour d'un axe dans n'importe quelle
direction qui passe par son centre, je
vais tourner la sphère, ça change pas sa
forme.
Je parle de la forme de la sphère, ça
change pas non plus sa position.
Et donc cette rotation laisse la sphère
invariante. Et donc les gens ont
identifié des groupes de symétrie
qui laissent la structure des
interactions disons invariantes. Par
exemple, le groupe de symétrie associé à
électromagnétisme pour ceux qui
connaissent c'est l'ensemble des nombres
complexes de modules égal à 1. C'est des
nombres qui s'écrivent sous la forme
exponentielle i alpha.
Et il se trouve que dans le cadre de la
mécanique quantique,
si on fait l'hypothèse que le groupe de
symétrie de l'électromagnétisme, c'est
l'ensemble des nombres qui s'écrivent
sous cette forme, alors le formalisme
est tel qui permet de calculer toutes
les propriétés de l'interaction.
L'identification du groupe détermine
l'interaction. L'identification de la
symétrie de l'interaction détermine
toutes ses propriétés. Et la chose
incroyable, c'est que très peu de temps
après, on a pu faire le même type
d'opération pour l'interaction faible et
l'interaction forte. On a trouvé un
groupe de symétrie pour l'interaction
faible qui s'appelle SU2, peu importe ce
qui désigne. On en a trouvé un pour
l'interaction forte qui s'appelle SU3.
Et [grognement] ce qui est
extraordinaire, c'est que le seul fait
de fixer ces groupes, de les identifier
détermine complètement la structure
des interactions. Et à cette époque-là,
on construit des nouveaux accélérateurs
de particules, on fait des collisions,
on a beaucoup de données expérimentales,
en tout cas, on a un nombre de données
qui augmente très rapidement au cours du
temps. Et il se trouve que la théorie
qu'on construit ainsi qui s'appelle le
modèle standard de la physique des
particules est une théorie qui rencontre
des événements qu'on peut détecter dans
les détecteurs de particules. Autrement
dit, on a un modèle, une théorie même
qui permet d'expliquer de façon assez
élégante parce que ces trois
interactions qui d'un point de vue euh
phénoménologique sont complètement
différentes en fait sont décrites
de la même façon par ce qu'on appelle
des théories de jauge. Un groupe de
symétrie détermine l'interseaction.
C'est pas le même groupe pour les trois
mais la le formalisme mathématique est
le même pour les trois. Donc ça donne un
côté très unificateur qui est toujours
apprécié parce qu'il est synonyme d'une
forme d'élégance. Bon et tout va bien
puisquon rencontre des des résultats. On
a une sorte de théorie physique qui
décrit parfaitement le monde de
l'infiniment petit.
Le problème et on on le constate
disons au début des années 60, c'est que
si on suppose
que les équations
de ce modèle sont justes
et si on regarde ce qu'elles impliqu, on
fait s d'expérience de pensée, qu'est-ce
qui se passerait si les équations
étaient vraiment justes ? Et bien, on se
rend compte que si les équations étaient
vraiment justes, alors les masses de
tous les ballons
qui médiatisent les interactions
devrait être nulle.
Autrement dit, toutes les interactions
devraient avoir une portée infinie et
devrait être médiatisé par des
particules de masse nulle.
Et ça va même plus loin parce que par
une sorte de contagion, si les ballons
ont une masse nulle, alors euh
les particules qui subissent ces
interactions doivent aussi avoir une
massi. Autrement dit, le modèle standard
qui marche très bien prédit, si on le
prend au sérieux, que les masses de
toutes les particules élémentaires
doivent être égales à zéro.
Ce qui n'est pas ce qu'on constate.
Les bosons W, Z0 qui médiatisent
l'interaction faible, je l'ai dit, sont
très lourds. Les électrons une masse non
nulle. Donc, il y a une contradiction
entre ce qu'on mesure et ce que dit ce
modèle. Comment résoudre cette
contradiction ?
Alors, avant de continuer, faut que je
fasse une précision sur ce qu'on appelle
la masse. La masse, c'est une notion
assez évidente. Ça mesure la la quantité
de matière contenue dans un objet. Ça
mesure sa substantialité.
C'est une grandeur mesurable
en kilogram et mesurante. Elle mesure le
degré de substantialité d'un corps. Et
dans notre esprit,
masse et matière sont deux notions qui
sont intriguées l'une à l'autre. J'ai
beaucoup de mal à penser
de la matière qui n'aurait pas de masse
et j'ai beaucoup de mal à penser de la
masse qui ne serait pas incarné en
particulier matière. Autrement dit, dès
que je pense masse, je pense matière.
Dès que je pense matière, je pense
masse.
Et c'est cette intrication
qu'on fait depuis toujours, au moins
depuis Aristote, entre matière et masse
que la découverte du bon X va défaire.
On va comprendre que la masse des
particules élémentaires n'est pas une
notion primitive qu'elles acquièrent du
seul fait qu'elles sont des particules
de matière.
On va comprendre que la masse des
particules élémentaires est une
propriété secondaire
qu'elles acquièrent du fait de leur
interaction avec le vide qui n'est pas
vide. Alors, comment est-ce qu'on est
arrivé là ?
Je vous l'ai dit, apparaît une
contradiction
entre ce qu'implique le modèle standard
de la physique des particules. Toutes
les particules élémentaires doivent
avoir une masse nulle et puis le fait de
constater que c'est pas vrai, elles ont
une masse non nulle. en général.
D'accord ? Alors, une petite précision
quand même. [grognement] Quand je prends
un corps
constitué d'autres corps plus petit,
j'ai tendance à penser que la masse
totale du corps est la somme des masses
de ces parties. Par exemple, si je
prends un sac de billes, bah la masse
d'un sac de billes, c'est la somme des
masses de toutes les billes qui sont
dedans plus la masse du sac. Donc,
j'ajoute les masses des constituants
pour avoir la masse totale. En fait,
c'est pas vrai.
Par exemple,
dans notre corps, la somme des masses de
nos particules élémentaires, électron et
quarc, c'est quelques pourcale.
Alors, d'où vient notre masse principale
? les 90 % ou plus qui font l'essentiel
de notre masse et bien la masse vient de
E= MC2 la formule d'Instein. C'est qu'en
fait il faut imaginer que nos particules
notamment nos quarc interagissent entre
eux très violemment. leur interaction
déploie une certaine énergie que je vais
appeler grand eux qui correspond à une
masse effective donnée par la formule
Einstein. Donc l'essentiel de notre
masse vient non pas de la masse de de
nos particules élémentaires mais du fait
que ces particules ont des danses
furieusement agitées et interagissent en
fabriquant ainsi de la masse effective.
Je ferme la parenthèse. Dès lors que
dans les 60, il y a une contradiction
entre ce que prévoit le modèle standard
et ce que donne les mesures,
les gens se disent il y a une
contradiction entre les faits et la
théorie. Donc la théorie est fausse. En
général, c'est comme ça qu'on raisonne.
La théorie est fausse [soupir]
et on cherche d'autres modèles. On met
au point de nouveaux scénarios pour
essayer d'expliquer les interactions
telles qu'on les observe à partir
d'autres concepts que ceux qui est
utilisé modèle standard.
Et puis en fait, il y a il y a trois
physiciens, trois jeunes physiciens qui
ont de façon indépendante la même idée
pendant l'été 64. Les deux premiers
s'appellent François Angler et Robert
Brut. Alors François Angler,
il est belge, il travaille à Bruxelles.
Robert Brut, il est américain et s'est
fait naturaliser belge. Et ensemble, ils
écrivent un article en juin 1964.
Et puis de façon indépendante,
un physicien écossais qui travaille tout
seul qui s'appelle Peter Higgs,
écrit un papier en août 1964,
quelques mois plus tard. Et quand je dis
papier, c'est vraiment des petits
papiers, c'est des articles d'une page
et demi avec des calculs,
des calculs de ce qu'on appelle la
théorie des champs. Donc difficile à
lire, mais l'idée
est la même dans les deux. Et en fait
l'idée c'est de dire
souvenons-nous de Galilée,
souvenons-nous de ce que dit Cé. Il le
cite pas mais je réinterprète à ma
façon. Le pari de la physique c'est
qu'on peut expliquer le réel par
l'impossible. C'est-à-dire que on peut
expliquer ce que nous détectons, ce que
nous mesurons, ce que nous observons
grâce à des lois physique qui
contredisent l'observation directe. Dans
le cas de Galilée, quand je dis quand il
dit tous les corps tombent à la même
vitesse dans le vide, cette loi est
vraie. Mais comment comprendre que cette
loi qui contredit l'observation pu
puisse expliquer quand même
l'observation
en disant quand on fait tomber des corps
dans l'atmosphère mais il y a la gravité
qui les fait tous tomber à la même
vitesse. Il y a d'autres forces la
résistance de l'air la poussée
d'archimètes qui sont responsables et
seulement elles du fait que les corps
lourdes ne tombent pas à la même vitesse
que les corps légers. Donc la loi qui
contredit l'observation oblige à une
réinterprétation de l'observation.
Bah ces physiciens vont lui reprendre ce
type d'argument pour dire
peut-être que les équations du modèle
standard qui disent que les particules
élémentaires ont une masse nulle ont
raison.
Peut-être qu'il est vrai que les
particules alimentaires ont une masse
nulle. Et nous qui pensons que ce n'est
pas le cas, peut-être nous trompons
depuis très longtemps sur
l'interprétation de ce qu'il faut
appeler la masse. Peut-être que la masse
n'est pas une propriété intrinsèque des
particules, mais une propriété
secondaire qui résulte de leur
interaction avec le vide qui du coup
n'est pas vide.
Et donc ces gens vont supposer que le
vide, ce qu'on appelle le vide, donc
l'espace vide si vous préférez contient
en tout point de l'espace un champ, un
champ un peu comme un champ de
température qui a une valeur en tout
point. Et en l'occurrence le champ en
question s'appelle le champ de X. On l'a
appelé du nom de du physicien écossais
que je viens de citer. Champ de X qui
est un champ scalaire. Scalaire ça veut
dire qu'il est très simple. Il est écrit
par un nombre scalaire comme un champ de
température. Il est partout présent dans
l'espace et ils imaginent que les
particules de masse nul qui sont toutes
de masse nul comme le dit le modèle
standard qui a raison toutes les
particules de masse nul interagissent
avec le champ plus ou moins fortement
et c'est le couplage qu'elles ont avec
le champ qui détermine leur masse. Nous
voyons qu'elles ont une masse ou une
inertie.
On a l'impression que c'est elle-même
qui possède cette inertie et cette masse
alors qu'en fait elle résulte de leur
interaction. C'est comme si les
particules se frottaient au vide.
D'accord ? Alors cette image est
évidemment à prendre avec des pincettes
parce que c'est pas un frottement, c'est
un couplage comme on dit. Il y a pas de
dissipation
mais l'idée c'est ça, c'est que ce qu'on
appelle la masse c'est simplement une
mesure du couplage que les particules
ont avec le vide qui n'est pas vide
puisqu'il contient un champ. Je vais
reprendre une métaphore qu'on cite
souvent, même si comme toutes les
autres, elle mérite d'être critiquée.
Imaginons que
le champ de X, ça soit un champ de
neige. Un champ de neige d'épaisseur
constante. L'amplitude même partout, il
est homogène.
Et imaginons que les particules
élémentaires
sans masse soit doté de petits skis.
et elle glisse sur le champ de neige. Si
le fartage des skis est parfait, ça veut
dire qu'il y a aucune forme de couplage,
aucune forme de frottement entre les
skis et le champ de neige et les
particules vont glisser
sans frottement et donc elles auront une
une vitesse égale à la vitesse de la
lumière.
Et nous qui les voyons passer, nous
dirons tiens, elles ont une masse nulle.
Si au contraire les particules ont des
skis qui sont mal fartées,
il va y avoir une forme de frottement et
la vitesse des particules sera plus
petite que la vitesse de la lumière et
nous dirons tiens elles ont une masse
non nulle. Autrement dit, cette
hypothèse que font les trois physiciens
que j'ai cité là, c'est l'idée que la
masse est simplement une mesure
de la mauvaise qualité
du fartage des skis, des particules.
Moins les skis sont fartés, sont bien
fartés, plus la masse, le couplage est
important et on est invité ainsi à
considérer que la masse des particules
est le résultat d'une interaction. Et
donc là, on a un cas intéressant puisque
il mélange à partir du désaccord entre
la théorie et les mesures une solution
de type ontologique et une solution de
type législatif. Puisqu'on dit il y a un
champ, il y a un champ qu'on a jamais vu
qui doit exister. Il y a non seulement
donc quelque chose de plus que ce qu'on
croyait dans l'univers et en plus il y a
une nouvelle interaction entre les
particules. Donc une nouvelle loi en
fait entre les particules et ce champ.
Et ça c'est une idée donc qui remonte au
la fin des années 60. Et en mécanique
quantique quand on a un champ comme ça
et ben il y a il y a des règles,
il y a des lois dans le formalisme qui
impliquent que ce champ doit être
structuré en canant. en Cantar. De la
même façon que dans le champ
électromagnétique il a des photons. Bah
là dans le champ de X, il doit y avoir
des particules qu'on appelle les bosons
de X qui sont les quantas de ce champ.
Alors boson, ça s'écrit comme ça. B O
S. Ça vient du nom d'un physicien indien
qui s'appelait Bose
[raclement de gorge] et qui a introduit
des particules obéissant à cette ce
genre de statistique dans les années 30.
Donc donc
voilà dans les années 20 pardon. Donc la
question c'est est-ce que c'est la
solution ? Est-ce que ces papiers là
donnent la bonne explication du
désaccord ou est-ce qu'il faut trouver
autre chose ? Alors le problème c'est
que une fois qu'on a fait l'hypothèse
que le boson de X existe, qu'on l'insère
dans le modèle standard, ça ça marche.
Sauf que le modèle standard ne dit pas
quelle doit être la masse de cette
particule.
Donc il faut il faut faire des essais.
Alors comment est-ce qu'on peut détecter
le boson de X ? Et ben on fait des
collisions de particules
[raclement de gorge] à très haute
énergie comme on le fait au Cernes à
Genève. Alors on a essayé de le faire
avec des électrons et des positons dans
une machine qui s'appelle le LEP qui
faisait 27 km de circonférence dans un
tunnel. les électrons tournent dans un
sens, les posites dans l'autre sens et
on crée des collisions.
[raclement de gorge] Et dans un tout
petit tout petit volume de de
l'espace-temps,
lors de ces collisions qui sont très
brèves, on recrée les conditions
physiques de l'univers primordial.
Donc très forte température, très forte
densité. Et comme nous pensons que les
lois physiques n'ont pas changé au cours
du temps, dès lors que nous répétons les
conditions physiques du passé,
nous voyons réapparaître les phénomènes
physiques du passé.
Et donc ces collisions,
c'est pas des machines à remonter dans
le temps, c'est des opérations par
lesquelles on recrée dans le présent des
phénomènes physiques qui se sont
déroulés dans le passé. D'accord ? Et en
fait quand on fait de telles collisions,
[raclement de gorge] on chauffe le vide.
Le ce qu'on appelle le vide quantique.
Le vide quantique c'est un c'est
l'espace rempli de particules virtuelles
qui sont fatiguées, qui n'ont pas assez
d'énergie pour exister vraiment. En
gros, elles ont une énergie inférieure
à leur masse multipliée par le carré de
la vitesse de la lumière. Elles sont pas
vraiment réelles parce qu'elles n'ont
pas leur énergie de masse. Et quand on
fait des collisions comme celles que je
viens de décrire, en fait, on transfère
à ces particules fatiguées l'énergie qui
leur manque de sorte qu'elles deviennent
réelles. Elles sortent du vide et on les
détecte. Et donc par des collisions, on
peut recréer les conditions physiques de
l'univers primordial et faire
réapparaître des phénomènes qui n'existe
plus aujourd'hui parce que l'univers est
devenu trop froid, pas assez
énergétique.
Avec le on avait pas assez d'énergie
pour détecter le boson de X, on ne
connaissait pas la masse, donc on l'a
pas vu. On a changé de machine. On a
remplacé le LEP par un le LHC
large adrome collider dans lequel on
fait entrer en collision non plus des
particules légèr comme les électrons et
les positie
et en 2012 après quelques années de
fonctionnement on a vu apparaître des
signaux qui sont la signature du bon de
X donc l'annonce de la découverte a été
faite le 4 juillet 12 et ça a prouvé que
cette hypothèse était la bonne. 48 ans
après qu'elle était formulée. Elle était
formulée en 64, la détection est en
2012. Donc 48 ans après, on a la preuve
que le boson de existe et que donc la
masse des particules élémentaires
provient de l'interaction qu'elles ont
avec un champ qui est partout présent
dans le vide. Alors on pourrait se dire
"Mais ça c'est de la physique des
particules
euh ça ne concerne que l'infiniment
petit en fait. pas tout à fait parce que
comme vous le savez certainement la
physique des particulières et la
cosmologie sont reliées comme je viens
de le dire quand on recrée les
conditions du passé on en apprend sur
l'univers tel qu'il était dans ses
phases primordiales hein et quand on
essaie de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
dans l'histoire de l'univers, on est
amené à concevoir que dans l'univers
primordial
le champ de X n'existait pas donc les
particules élémentaires n'avaient pas de
masse et était des sortes de fantômes
sans masse qui allaient à la vitesse de
la lumière.
Enteractivité, quand une particule n'a
pas de masse, elle a pas de temps
propre. Il y a pas de référentiel qui
lui soit associé dans lequel on puisse
définir un temps pour cette particule.
Donc, il y a pas de temps propre pour
les particules. Et l'idée, c'est que
tout d'un coup, tout d'un coup, le champ
de X est apparu et s'est installé
partout dans l'espace. Dès qu'il est
apparu, les particules qui jusque là
n'avaient pas de masse se sont couplées
à ce champ plus ou moins. Ça leur a
donné une masse non nulle qui a engendré
pour elle un temps propre. Donc donc
l'apparition du champ de X et des
beausons associés, c'est l'apparition en
fait du du temps de la matière, on
pourrait dire. D'ailleurs, il y a des
gens qui sachant que j'allais faire cet
exposé m'ont demandé une anagramme.
Il y en a une très belle qui dit à peu
près ce que je viens de dire. Alors le
boson son vrai nom en physique c'est le
boson scalaire. Le boson scalaire a
pourramme bière sans alcool. Bon bière
sans alcool sachant que ici on a
physicien symbol c'est une idée
insupportable.
Alors on peut prendre comme autre
expression le boson scalaire de X.
Et là il y a une belle anagramme qui est
l'horloge des anges ici-bas.
Ça correspond à peu près à ce que je
viens de dire à savoir que au départ les
particules élémentaires n'avaient pas de
masse. Une sorte d'ange véloce qui se
propageait dans l'espace à la vitesse de
la lumière et puis tout d'un coup elles
ont acquis de la masse et donc une
horloge.
Alors qu'est-ce qui a fait que le champ
de X est apparu ? Et ben c'est
[grognement]
dans le jargon des physiciens, c'est ce
qu'on appelle une brisure spontanée de
symétrie.
Alors qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une brisure
spontanée de symétrie ? Si je prends par
exemple ce stylo, je le mets comme ça,
je pars d'une situation initiale dans
laquelle c'est symétrique
et puis je le laisse tomber, je le
lâche, il va tomber dans une certaine
direction,
il va réduire son énergie et en se
faisant, il va briser la symétrie qui
était là au départ parce qu'au départ,
on avait une invariance par rotation et
à la fin, il y a une direction
privilégiée qui a été choisie. Donc
l'état final est moins symétrique que
l'état initial. Il y a une brisure
spontanée symétrique et on pense que
c'est un phénomène de ce type-là qui a
engendré l'apparition du champ de Yve et
donc a fait démarrer le temps de la
matière.
Voilà
des questions camarades ?
Impeccable.
J'ai oublié [grognement] de dire que
François Angler et Peter X ont eu le
prix Nobel en 2013 par Robert Bou parce
qu'il était mort quelques années
auparavant.
Et ce qui est assez étonnant, c'est que
ils se sont rencontrés pour la première
fois le 4 juillet 2012 dans
l'amphithéâtre du CERNE où les résultats
des expériences du LH étaient présenté
pour la première fois. Ils étaient tous
les deux dans la salle, il s'était
jamais parlé mais ils ont reçu le prix
Nobel ensemble.
[grognement]
Qu'est-ce que le qu'est-ce que la
physique va pouvoir nous apporter avec
tout ça ? Et qu'est-ce que les les
physiciens vont pouvoir euh
nous extrapoler de cette situation ?
[raclement de gorge]
Ben, il faut quand même voir que c'est
quand même des découvertes fabuleuses,
non ? Quand d'abord ça a tranché une
question qui a occupé les esprits
pendant 48 ans. Est-ce que c'est comme
ça qu'il faut comprendre la masse des
particules élémentaires ou pas ? La
question est tranchée. Il y avait des
hypothèses alternatives, je les ai pas
cité mais il y avait des gens qui
imaginaient d'autres choses. Donc la
physique avance comme ça. On tranche des
questions. Maintenant, est-ce qu'il y
aura des applications pratiques du bon X
? Sa durée de vie est 10^- 23 secondes.
Donc on va pas faire des médicaments
avec. C'est très cher d'en fabriquer un.
Il a une durée de vie très courte. En
revanche, mais c'est une défense, c'est
une illustration du deuxème ordre. Pour
construire le LHC,
tunnel de 27 km avec des aimants
supraconducteurs, il [grognement] a
fallu inventer des systèmes de
cryogénie, perfectionner la qualité des
aimants et ces aimants, le système de
d'acquisition de données, de traitement
de l'information a lui aussi bénéficié
de cet investissement dans une recherche
très fondamentale. Les retombées, c'est
des retombées dans le médical, dans le
big data, dans toutes sortes de choses.
Donc ce sont des retombées indirectes,
mais on ne peut pas dire que la
découverte de Bandix va enclencher une
industrie comme a pu enclencher la
découverte de l'électron à la fin du 19e
siècle. C'est pas le même genre de
chose.
Si j'étais malhonnête, je pourrais dire
si j'étais malhonnête, ce qui est pas le
cas, je pourrais dire "Mais finalement,
on a compris l'origine de la masse
et on ne peut pas exclure qu'un jour des
ingénieurs utilisant ce résultat de
physique ne viendront pas concevoir une
machine
s'appuyant sur ses résultats qui
permettra de résoudre un problème de
santé publique qui s'appelle l'obésité.
On pourrait changer la masse des gens.
Évidemment, ça serait mentir, mais on
peut toujours faire des promesses
mensongères. On
pourrait voyager plus vite peut-être.
Non,
non, non, je vois pas pourquoi. Non,
non. Tout ça est dans un cadre de
relativité absolument
parfait. Il y a il y a aucune porte qui
s'ouvre vers les voyages dans le temps
ou je ne sais quoi. Évidemment, on peut
toujours jouer avec les mots et dire que
quand on fait une collision dans le
présent, comme on recrée les conditions
du passé, c'est comme si on est dans le
passé.
Non, on recrée dans le présent les
conditions du passé et donc on fait
réapparaître
dans le présent des phénomènes qui sont
des réser dans le passé. Donc pour
l'univers, c'est plutôt une cure de
jouvance qu'un voyage dans le temps.
Je vais je vais me retourner vers mon
compère qui doit avoir son micro
devant toi. Devant toi,
allumé,
il est allumé. Tu veux le bien ?
Tu l' éteint ? Tu l' éteins.
Attends, reprends le mien. Prends le
mien.
C'est bon.
Ouais.
Euh bah sur le boson de de X, je pense
qu'on on a fait pas mal de choses. Je
voulais savoir en terme de découverte
euh qu'on a fait récemment, en tout cas
il y a pas il y a très longtemps, est-ce
que ça vous parle la gnakea ?
Ah c'est sur les galaxies ça. C'est
galax. Oui. Alors déjà ce que j'aurais
dû dire c'est que pour l'instant enfin
avec la découverte du Bond X le modèle
standard est complet. C'estàd toutes les
particules dont le modèle standard exige
qu'elles existent ont été détectées.
Donc tous les quarc, il y en a 6, tous
les leptons
et le boson 2 X et puis toutes les
particules qui médiatisent l'interaction
sont découvertes. Donc on pourrait dire
le modèle standard euh il a fait ses
preuves, c'est la bonne théorie pour
décrire le monde de l'infiniment petit.
Il y a un problème
comme je l'ai dit, le modèle standard ne
contient pas la gravitation.
On fait exactement comme si la
gravitation n'existait pas. OK ? Or, ça
c'est quand même un problème parce que
si on monte en énergie,
la gravitation va intervenir. Et la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on peut
réconcilier le modèle standard qui ne
contient pas la gravitation et qui
s'appuie simplement sur la mécanique
quantique ? Comment peut-on réconcilier
ce modèle ? avec la théorie de la
gravitation élaborée par Einstein en
1915 qui s'appelle la relativité
générale. On pour dire c'est simple, il
suffit de le rajouter. C'est pas si
simple parce que l'espace-temps du
modèle standard, c'est un espace-temps
rigide, statique, qui est indépendant de
ce qui se passe en son sein. C'est comme
une scène de théâtre dont la structure
est indépendante de la pièce qui s'y
joue. Alors que l'espace-temps de la
réalité générale, c'est un espace-temps
qui est souple et dynamique et qui est
modifié pour ce qui est de sa métrie, sa
géométrie, par ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur. Et on a donc une physique
aujourd'hui un peu schizophrène avec
d'un côté la relativité générale qui ne
décrit que la gravitation avec un
formalisme spécifique et puis les trois
autres interactions qui sont décrites
ensemble dans le modèle standard avec un
autre formalisme spécifique. Et il se
trouve que quand on essaie de les mettre
ensemble, ça présente des difficultés.
il faut changer l'espace-temps,
augmenter le nombre de dimensions euh ou
bien quantifier l'espace-temps. Enfin,
ça devient assez compliqué et on sait
pas trop comment faire. Donc la suite de
l'histoire,
c'est de faire fonctionner le lâcher
comme il fonctionne aujourd'hui pendant
quelques années et de voir si on
pourrait détecter de nouvelles
particules plus massives euh qui
viendraient nous aider à voir quelle est
la bonne voie pour unifier la physique
quantique et la gravitation. Il y a un
autre problème dont j'ai pas parlé qui
un problème de cosmologie comme celui
que vous évoquez, c'est le problème de
la matière noire. Alors le problème de
la matière noire, on en parle depuis des
années, je pense c'est un problème qui
est mal nommé au sens où en l'appelant
ainsi, on fait comme si la solution du
problème dont on va parler était une
solution ontologique. On dit il y a de
la matière qu'on connaît pas et cetera.
Mais quel est le problème ? Le problème
c'est que quand on regarde la dynamique
des galaxies, comment les galaxies
tournent sur elles-mêmes ou se déplacent
les unes par rapport aux autres, on se
rend compte que la force qui est
responsable de leur dynamique mutuelle,
c'est la gravitation.
D'accord ? Et la gravitation, elle est
décrite par la théorie d'Instein.
Et on calcule
parfaitement la dynamique des galaxies.
On a des équations qui disent exactement
ce qu'on observe
à la condition à la condition bizarre
de mettre dans les équations 10 fois
plus de masse que celle qu'on observe.
Et donc on dit il doit y avoir de la
matière noire,
de la matière noire, de la matière qu'on
ne voit pas, qui n'a met pas de lumière,
qui agit gravitationnellement sur les
galaxies.
Et la question est de quoi est faite
cette matière noire ? Donc là encore, il
y a une sorte de désaccord entre le
calcul et l'observation. Et ce
désaccord, on le résout de façon
ontologique en disant il doit y avoir de
la matière
cachée constitué de particules
différentes de celles que nous
connaissons. La question est que sont
ces particules ? Faut les trouver. La
physique c'est pas une métaphysique.
Donc il faut en passer par l'expérience.
Et la suite de l'histoire va nous dire
si le LHC ou d'autres expériences sont
capables de détecter ou non les
particules de matière noire.
Il y a des gens qui commencent à dire
"Mais pour l'instant, on a rien vu. Donc
peut-être que les particules de matière
noire n'existent pas, peut-être qu'il
n'y a pas de matière noire et peut-être
que la solution du problème que je viens
d'évoquer est une solution non pas
ontologique mais législative.
C'est-à-dire, il faut changer les
équations de la gravité pour rendre
compte du mouvement des galaxies sans
avoir à invoquer l'existence
hypothétique d'une matière noire. Ça, je
pense c'est le grand enjeu des années
qui viennent et euh je peux pas vous
dire comment ça va se passer parce qu'on
ne sait pas dire à l'avance
et je l'ai illustré par des exemples
historiques, on sait pas dire à l'avance
si un conflit entre théorie et
expérience va se régler par une solution
autologique ou législative dans
l'histoire. Il y a eu des cas où c'était
la première solution et d'autres cas où
c'était la seconde, on peut pas le dire
à l'avance.
Et du coup, j'ai entendu parler de la
théorie de l'inflation.
L'inflation c'est pas c'est pas vraiment
une théorie, c'est une hypothèse hein.
L'inflation alors
vous êtes conscient que toutes ces
questions sont très compliquées ?
Oui.
Attends.
Est-ce que ça se sent dans ce que je dis
ou est-ce que je le fais trop simple ou
trop clair ? Ça va.
[grognement]
Alors
pour comprendre l'inflation, faut que je
dise un mot sur la relativité générale
d'Instein.
Euh
comment est-ce que ça a démarré ? Alors,
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure du principe
d'inertie.
Principe d'inertie dit un corps qui
n'est soumis à aucune force
à un mouvement rectiligne et uniforme.
Bon, alors on sait qu'il y a de la
gravitation partout. Il y a de la masse
partout, il y a de la gravitation
partout. Donc tous les corps massifs, où
qu'ils soient dans l'univers
subit sûrement une force qui est leur
poids.
Ça veut dire que le principe d'inertie
correspond à un énoncé qui est en
quelque sorte fictif
qu'il n'existe aucun endroit dans
l'univers où les corps ne subissent
aucune force puisque partout ils
subissent la gravitation. Et Einsteiner
quand il était assur cette remarque, le
principe diversique est un des principes
fondamentaux de la mécanique, on peut
pas le tester directement et si on
l'accepte tel quel, ça veut dire qu'on
accepte de construire la physique sur du
sable. C'est sans expression. Mais dit,
il y a une autre solution peut-être,
c'est que la gravitation ne soit pas une
force.
la gravitation ne soit pas une force de
sorte que si la gravitation n'est pas
une force, les objets qui subissent la
gravitation ne subissant pas de force
peuvent avoir un mouvement inertiel. Et
c'est en effet ce qui va démontrer
que la gravitation n'est pas une force,
c'est une déformation de l'espace-temps.
Alors, comment est-ce qu'il est arrivé à
cette conclusion assez étrange ? Grâce à
ce qu'on appelle des expériences de
pensées. Une expérience de pensée, c'est
pas une expérience où je me gratte la
tête et je me mets à réfléchir. Une
expéence de pensée, c'est je me décale
de ce que l'univers me montre pour
interroger ce que les lois physiques
prédient dans une situation que je peux
imaginer mais pas créée.
Et en l'occurrence, en 1907,
Einstein lorsqu'il est au bureau des
brevets à Bern a fait une expérience de
pensée, il a imaginé qu'il était en
chute libre. que son corps était en
chute libre et il s'est rendu compte et
c'est d'ailleurs assez facile à voir que
quand son corps est en chute libre ben
il sent plus son poids. Pourquoi il sent
plus son poids ? Parce que les objets
qui tombent avec lui, ce stylo par
exemple, il le lâche comme tous les
corps tombent à la même vitesse dans le
vide. Bah par rapport à lui, le stylo ne
tombe plus. Donc il est en apesanteur
par rapport à lui. Donc il comprend que
l'appesanteur nous fait tomber.
Donc la chute est un effet d'une cause
qui est la pesanteur. Mais en tombant,
nous annulons la cause qui nous fait
tomber. Autrement dit, la pesanteur, le
fait de subir la pesanteur nous met en
apesanteur
sur d'équivalence entre l'accélération
et la gravitation, ça va l'amener à
énoncer le principe d'équivalence
et le principe d'équivalence va lui-même
quand il l'appliquera à la lumière lui
faire comprendre que la lumière, bien
qu'elle soit de masse nulle, est déviée
par la gravitation.
Et pour rendre compte de la déviation de
la lumière par la gravitation, il va
être obligé de courber l'espace-temps de
sorte que la gravitation ne sera plus
une force qui s'exerce dans l'espace
entre les objets, mais sera une
déformation de l'espace-temps. De sorte
que au bout du compte, la gravité
n'est plus une force, c'est simplement
une déformation de la métrique, de la
géométrie si vous préférez, de
[grognement] sorte que par exemple, nous
voyons que la Terre a une trajectoire
elliptique autour du Soleil.
Nous disons, il y a une force de
gravitation qui attire la Terre vers le
soleil. La lecture d'Instein, c'est la
terre en fait va en ligne droite,
mouvement inertiel dans un espace-temp
qui est courbé, ce qui lui donne une
trajectoire curvile.
Alors maintenant, pour répondre à votre
question, qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'inflation ? Ben, en relativité
générale, qui est la théorie qu'on
utilise pour faire de la cosmologie,
ce qu'on voit c'est que l'espace-temps
ou l'espace plutôt est plat. Il est
plat. Alors, plat ça veut pas dire plan.
Je suis pas en train de dire qu'il est à
deux dimensions. Quand je dis qu'il est
plat, ça veut dire qu'il il a pas il a
pas une courbure généralisée. Il y a des
courbures locales induites par le soleil
ou d'autres objets astrophysiques. Mais
si je prends trois galaxies par exemple,
elles forment un triangle. Et si je
regarde la somme des angles du triangle,
je trouve 180°
comme dans un espace clidien ordinaire.
Alors que si je prends trois points sur
la surface d'une orange, je trace une
espèce de triangle à partir de ces trois
points, la somme des angles, ça sera
plus 180°.
D'accord ? Et donc c'est plat, ça veut
dire que la courbure généralisée est
égale à é zéro ? Ça pourrait être
n'importe quelle valeur positive ou
n'importe quelle valeur négative. On
trouve zéro. Alors il y a des gens qui
vous diront "Bah c'est zéro, c'est zéro.
On n' pas interrogé la question de
savoir pourquoi c'est zéro." Et il y a
d'autres gens moins satisfaits qui
disent il faut expliquer zéro. Et c'est
là que dans les années 80 ça tombe de
cosmologistes ont fait l'hypothèse de
l'inflation.
C'est l'idée que dans l'univers
primordial les distances dans l'univers
ont augmenté d'un facteur énorme 10^ 50
on un temps très court 10- 32 secondes.
Donc c'est pas un train de sénateur
hein. Ça veut dire que l'univers en fait
a acquis presque d'un seul coup plus de
la moitié de sa taille. Je parle de
l'univers observable. D'accord ? Et si
on fait cette hypothèse,
alors on comprend pourquoi l'univers
observable,
je pas pas l'univers total ou réel, je
connais pas. L'univers observable, lui
il est plein. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on en
voit qu'un petit bout. L'univers
observable n'est qu'un petit bout.
L'univers, c'est un peu comme quand vous
êtes sur un ballon, vous êtes à la
surface d'un ballon, il d'une baudruche
là. Voilà une baudruche. OK ? Imaginez
que vous soyez là et vous êtes miope.
Vous voyez que l'environnement immédiat
de votre position, vous aurez
l'impression que c'est plat parce que la
courbure généralisée vous échappe et
l'inflation
explique
la platitude de l'univers observable en
disant que en fait l'univers réel est
tellement plus grand que la courbure
qu'il a nous échappe.
Alors juste pour reprendre je pour
l'exemple d'Instein sur la chute, il y a
une chose qu'on voit tous les jours,
c'est quand on est dans un train et
qu'un autre part et on voit
le le problème euh optique qu'on peut
voir quand on se trouve dans un train.
Voilà, c'était juste un petit exemple
comme ça que j'avais vu.
Ouais,
ça c'est la relativité. C'estd que le
mouvement est relatif pour le coup.
Exactement. Et sinon, on voit aussi de
très belles images sur internet. Euh et
c'est ce qu'on appelle le fond diffus
euh cosmologique.
Ouais.
Est-ce qu'on peut on peut en parler al
le fond cosmologique a été observé pour
la première fois 1900 euh
je crois qui a été beaucoup plus
finement analysé par d'autres détecteurs
emportés sur des satellites comme plank
ou map. Le fond dif cosmologique
c'est une c'est pas une trace des
origines. Disons que c'est dans les
modèles de Big Bang classique, dans les
380000 années qui suivent le Big Bang,
la densité de matière est tellement
importante
que la lumière ne peut pas se propager.
Autrement dit, dès qu'un photon fait un
pas, il entre en collision avec une
particule qui dévit sa trajectoire. Donc
la lumière n'est pas libre de se
propager librement dans l'espace.
Puis comme il y a une expansion
l'univers, la température baisse, elle
finit par attendre 4000°.
Et quand elle a 4000°,
en gros, l'énergie des photons n'est pas
suffisante pour casser les atomes. Donc
les premiers atomes se forment, atomes
d'hydrogène avec un proton, un électron
et ces atomes peuvent être traversés par
la lumière. Et donc tout d'un coup, la
lumière devient capable de se propager
librement dans l'espace.
D'accord ? Et ça se passe donc 380000
ans après le Big Bang. Et ce fond diffus
cosmologique, il existe encore
aujourd'hui partout présent dans
l'univers. Évidemment, sa température a
baissée puisque l'univers c'est dilaté,
donc il est plus froid. Et ce
rayonnement diffus, c'est une trace,
c'est la trace résiduelle de ce
rayonnement qui s'est libéré quelques
centaines de milliers d'années après le
Bigb. Et en l'étudiant finement, en
regardant sa sa structuration, disons,
on a des indications sur ce qui se
passait dans les phases d'avant.
Merci.
Tu
Je reprends.
Ouais. [grognement]
Euh, on a un autre scientifique français
qui est en train de nous intéresser en
ce moment, qui est un peu sulfureux pour
certains. Il s'appelle Jean-Pierre
Petit.
Est-ce que ça vous parle ? Oui, je le
connais bien. Oui. Est-ce que
il a un modèle qui s'appelle Janus.
Tout à fait.
Ouais.
Est-ce qu'on peut en parler ?
Non, parce que j'ai pas trop étudié ça.
Je suis pas compétent. Je sais qu'il a
des il a du mal à se faire entendre.
Ouais.
C'est l'idée qu'il y a des mondes
d'antimatière et de matière que
l'univers est en fait séparé et qu'on
peut expliquer ce qu'on voit sans
matière noire.
On s'est pas encore penché sur le on est
en train de préparer.
Moi je suis pas moi je suis pas habilité
à faire la
la
la promo de quelqu'un d'autre. Non,
c'est pas une question de promotion,
c'est c'est vos experts d'étudier ça.
D'accord. Et pourquoi vous dites qu'il a
du mal à se faire entendre ? Bah
en tout cas, il se plaint de avoir du
mal à se faire entendre.
Oui.
Alors nous d'autres ?
Non, je crois.
On est bon. Est-ce que vous voyez
quelque chose d'autre à aborder avec
nous ?
Non, je pense que j'ai tout dit.
C'est vrai.
Si on invite Jean-Pierre Petit, est-ce
que vous voulez interagir avec lui sur
son modèle ?
Bien sûr. [souffle coupé][soupir]
Étienne Clin. Merci.
Merci à vous. Excellente soirée coupé.
[musique]